[Music]
as expected josh rosen present and
accounted for for the voluntary
off-season program which began for the
cardinals this week
not expected he has been
as a practical matter muzzled by the
team not made available to reporters now
look he can say anything he wants to say
he could do an interview on a radio show
he could he could tweet out any thoughts
he may have the players nowadays can say
and do whatever they want when it comes
to making their thoughts known but you
know the idea that that
you don't make the guy available to
answer some basic questions we know what
the questions are going to be and i
think josh rosen is more than smart
enough to to say the predictable things
that we would expect look i can't
control anything as it relates to the
possibility he would be traded obviously
i can't control any of it i'm here to
work i'm the quarterback of the arizona
cardinals until they tell me differently
and if something happens then i'll be
ready to adjust to the new circumstances
i i don't know why
you don't put him out there and let him
say those things yeah i mean i guess
here's here would be my few you know
experienced football reasons maybe why
not and just you know again i've been
around the sport a whole for a long time
and grew up around it i mean yes i'm
with you i don't get it either but one
the first thing i think of and i said
this to start the show maybe they just
you know hey it's the first day back and
they don't want to start a media frenzy
you know that could be the first thing
they want to do hey let's just get
everybody in the building let's not make
it all about one player blah blah blah
you know two maybe josh rosen knows more
about the situation than than uh we
would think he knows maybe they're
afraid of something he might say to tell
you know give a tell about what the
arizona cardinals are doing i find that
unlikely the the third thing is uh
you know maybe he was scheduled to talk
maybe they realized josh rosen's not
very happy and he might say something
and maybe they want to have another
conversation about where he stands with
the team and maybe that's why they
didn't trust him because maybe they know
he's a little pissed off that he's in
this situation and that you know he
might give the media uh a little sound
bite or something like that i'm with you
i would have taken the approach that
you're talking about i'm just throwing
out some options there to be maybe why
the team didn't want him to talk on a
day like yesterday
i just can't imagine this happening if
frozen's not on board with it because if
he wants to talk and the team says no
well he can talk he he can talk anywhere
he wants he could call us he could call
chris sims unbutton pftpf he could call
any of the radio stations out in arizona
if he really wants to talk and remember
it wasn't that long ago that we were
speculating that he was the source for
joel klatt's report about the cardinal
not the cardinals but the chargers the
patriots and the giants being interested
in rosen and a second round pick being
on the table so i mean look this guy is
caught in limbo and there is a certain
amount of disrespect that he has to be
feeling while he's he's just waiting for
some update on what in the world is
going on with his life
but uh i i what would you have done mike
like what would you have done yesterday
if you're josh rosen i'd make i i i
would have i would have said i'd like to
speak i'd like to speak why are we
running from this well even before that
though would you even shown up yesterday
i mean i think that's a valid question
too i mean there's nothing like i
wouldn't have been mad at josh rosen if
he didn't show up yesterday and he just
said you know what no no no
i i would i would be i'd be what because
then you end up see you you look like
the victim as long as you go and do
everything you're supposed to do you
then if you all of a sudden don't show
up you give people a reason to say he's
exactly what we thought he was going to
be he's not a player he's not on board i
think you show up and you go about your
business and you wait for further
instructions whatever those instructions
may be further pft live is coming right
after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports